we have now seen yet another shooty
gotwa costume for Doctor Who and also
get our first Glimpse at Jonathan Groff
here you go
I'm not gonna lie
the costumes might be the thing I'm most
excited about right now I've expressed
recently that a lot of the moves being
made in terms of the creative people
being brought on and some other things
make me a little bit nervous that this
new era of Russell T Davis running
Doctor Who won't be what I wanted to be
which is to be something new and not
just trying to recapture the last time
he was showrunner but I'm really liking
how varied
the doctor's outfits are like massively
now granted they seem to be largely at
least what we've seen so far being
changed to match different eras but like
it's not even centering around a common
sense of style like uh the 12th doctor's
code or the 11th doctors bow tie it's
all over the place it's like his main
thing is just being the most fashionable
guy in the room and I dig it